all right my jaw libras next up we have
a game and made by the same guy who made
unicorn semi slap psych drop he made
salt meat factory it's a game about
click and drag me into the boxes alright
so um where are you going meet some a
pirate works in a meat factory with a
lot of [ __ ] meat and my goal is to
grab it the meat and then salt it I
would suppose oh god what are you doing
me why did I tell you to merge with a
salt box thing dammit God get out there
I got you stupid salty meat make me
salty you salty [ __ ] don't he likes it
way too much good tap you're not support
what did I tell you one second I go god
damn it why don't you work I flipped it
even for you well if you want to merge
with a damn box you [ __ ] then keep doing
it see if I care
push form wait for me at what does that
even mean haha that was a joke I got a
damn it you saw your first meet your
boss is damn it I didn't see what it
said I saw some more meets that suppose
damn it I missed a close enough who
woulda thought salting meat was this
hard they really need that much salt for
the meat though you know people look at
last of us and say hey that was an
emotional game I look at salt meat
factory and I say hey I have a boner
right now and I can't explain it and it
makes me feel emotional almost like I'm
when I play lots of us so I'd say that's
pretty good
alright what else can you do here
there's a dartboard oh portal 2 inspired
my name is Bob of course damn it bad how
did you lose your arm Bob let's throw it
that was pretty good Bob how do I wear
this nametag there we go I knit I'm
wearing it
oh I didn't log in at work god dammit
I'm working for free
if only I could whoa I did it and I got
an achievement for stamping my card
that's all thanks game let's see if we
can get an achievement for throwing this
piece of [ __ ] ah play darts ok enough
back to work achievement told me to get
back to work site
I better get back to work huh god I love
my job
technically this is my job so yep I
don't know what kind of meat it is I
would assume some kind of dinosaur
oh that meat is still alive I swear to
God I saw it move
what the [ __ ] are you doing meat I got
my one eye on your yard get it cuz I'm a
pirate no it's okay
what if I become a meat yes let's try
that I need to escape this place yarr
I will be meat now we are music goodbye
okay dammit
a cat son of a snake what are you doing
meat I told you not to sing no one likes
a singing meat alright damn it come here
I'm gonna have to teach you a lesson you
piece of [ __ ] oh god you piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh god don't merge with the
wall damn it me come back here you piece
of [ __ ] stop let's make a meat wall Oh
what the [ __ ] is that
it's Justin Bieber's dingdong it's been
lost for so long go in the wall ah god
damn it I didn't know this was a horror
game oh what an exhausting day at work
well we'll need to take a little break
there so here's a game that I've waited
for a couple of years it says touch that
but question why you touch that but
question that but learn its secret
transcend into a higher state of
consciousness become a better person but
great I'm not sure if I want to touch to
bite but I will indeed
touch the bite there we go I'm touching
the bite that's it that's [ __ ] it
okay next up last chance supermarket I
[ __ ] out too late every our last
chance
Oh get out of my way passage son of a
[ __ ]
damn it you died you died in a shopping
cart accident your family was mortified
and Christmas is a flop damn it
alright I need an alarm clock there's no
time to see I'm just gonna buy all this
stuff
am I getting the right stuff here yes I
got one of the right oh okay
not that person's crashed milk we need
that ah son of a [ __ ] I died so far I
don't need any of this [ __ ] oh god I
just ran over a dead guy I think I have
time to care if I need any of this
running out of money here yeah what are
you looking at where you go damn it oh
we got all the mini Xmas trees awesome
oh Jesus Christ severs close okay forget
all the muffins my grandpa I need all
the muffins milk orange juice [ __ ] I got
I'm I'm getting too many stuff here it's
not good there we go
orange juice yes milk damn it my cart
exploded really I need those mini accent
streets there we go all right let's get
laptops laptops are over here six
laptops why do I need so many [ __ ]
laptops son of a [ __ ] that was close Oh
God we need those ah
watch your Jesus Christ God look at how
many dead people there are already just
the parts what the [ __ ] is a part no you
putz I think I got one part are your
parts where's the damn box where's the
pot step
someone help me that's frying pans pots
pots pots
oh those are the pots one my I need one
more damn pot one more pot god dammit
I think it's F all right fine we'll be
fine I just missed one pot I'm sure it's
fine money spend the stuff get in one
well that's the problem for everyone
going shopping
well that was games pretty cool I like
it so that was three free games in Poots
I hope you guys enjoy these
recommendations in these videos if you
do please leave a like that's all I ask
and as always stay awesome